would you say because you have had some
you've had some pretty crazy like
brushes with almost losing your life
over the years right
um was it last year that someone tried
to shoot at you or you're going to Vegas
I think it was like last year two years
ago yeah and then something like that
also kind of happened in like 2015
uh 2015 yeah I got I got shot yeah
I mean you've had some serious brushes
with death yeah LA's crazy though [ __ ]
for sure it's only getting worse but do
you like when that has happened to you I
had a similar situation
uh
uh I didn't have anyone try to kill me I
almost killed kill my [ __ ] cell phone
not not on purpose
um but uh yesterday like shook me man
like I'm like damn I could have [ __ ]
like literally died like yeah you know
I've I've had a lot of experiences with
that one thing I kind of learned is like
riding around with you know in the
Lambos and three Corvettes following
behind you and riding around in these
cars and just being kind of loud it's
not really like the smartest thing to do
or the safest thing to do you know um
and I used to roll around like that a
lot but these days I'm kind of like more
I'm just I'm just smarter about it I
don't really like the all the crazy loud
bright colored cars right because you
seem to be like a pretty peaceful guy
yeah I could get wild at times though no
but I just mean in terms of like you put
a lot of positive energy into the world
like to me your music is like it's not
very negative it's not like you're
talking like a bunch of crazy like but I
like to have fun though you do like to
have fun a lot of fun you do like to
have fun sometimes on Instagram
[Laughter]
but you know I just I the older I get
the more I realize like okay
I gotta move smart yeah because and I've
learned from a lot in the past but now
I'm just like okay if we go somewhere if
we do something we have to be strategic
and militant and you know move the right
way especially with what's going on you
know these days it's just it's [ __ ]
right now it's [ __ ] it's too crazy